I myself I am excited because I got to
play the wolf among us by Telltale Games
telltale games they made the walking
dead game the good walking dead game
winner of Game of the Year so when I
heard they were coming out with a new
game I was instantly interested if not
absolutely excited so I got to play this
game in this game it's fairy tales it's
like that show once upon the time Meets
The Walking Dead by Telltale Games with
all the language and violence and
gratuity of The Walking Dead know that
it was really good dudas but it was
violent and now we have fairy tale
characters in this world you think my
job is easy you try keeping a bunch of
fables from killing each other you play
as the big bad wolf he's like the
sheriff of the modern town and by
monitored town I mean city and world he
keeps an eye on all the fairytale
creatures he makes sure that they don't
kill themselves off and they're under
control and then everything starts going
wrong and after that it's a telltale
Game with that fairytale element I was
playing the segment where you go into
this place where this dude who looks
just like Captain Spaulding from house
of two thousand Corpses I'm telling you
if the guy's not voiced by Captain
Spaulding they just made this guy look
like Captain Spaulding because they like
house up about a thousand Corpses anyhow
he's beaten down this hooker and so you
throw him out a window and you start
fighting them there's a little frog guy
and all these fairy tale elements with
the telltale games I'm getting that [ __ ]
and it's gonna be released a
chapter-by-chapter like the telltale
games Walking Dead was so Oh did well
there goes my money sequentially
speaking
knows you big bad wolf
and one of the most interesting looking
games at pax has to be watchdogs when I
first offered to watch dogs I thought it
was really cool but I wanted to do a
video about it when I actually saw some
real footage and some real revelation
firsthand at pax and I finally did and I
used to think to myself is kind of like
an assassin's creed in modern-day vibe
it still has that vibe but it really
isn't as much of a rip off as you might
have initially thought it was all in all
well from the carjackings I thought I
saw in the footage I would actually say
is more like Grand Theft Auto but it
goes in a really interesting concept
everything's interconnected tablets
laptops droids it's kind of like that
today and now this whole city operates
on the functionality that everything is
literally connected within the city and
the city optimizes everything through
automations for maximum performance he
plays a guy who knows that now you hack
everything to your means I didn't tell
us much about the plot because they're
not idiots not going to spoil a game
like that but one of the most
interesting things I found is that
there's a tablet app for the game
usually when game is try to do a tablet
cross-promotion it doesn't always work
out for me because this kind of force is
like what does that have to do with the
game but this tablet app actually works
with the game in multiplayer whoever has
the tablet app it's an overhead view of
the city they're in a helicopter the
person playing the console version sees
the helicopter above them and they're
tracking down the player and they're
they're messing with all the automation
to they're shutting down traffic lights
are notifying police officers they're
making drawbridges go up there making
that guy's life a living hell you got to
get away from the helicopter now I'm
looking forward to getting the tablet
app also which I never do in games and
tell your watchdogs one of the most
anticipated games for me coming out this
year I'm telling you this is this is one
to look forward to
you